Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
2015 yılıydı,
çok heyecanlıydım.
"Birbirimize olan aşkımız,
upuzun iki gölgenin
gerçeklik umudu olmadan
öpüşmeye çalışması gibi,"
dedi bana onu çok
sevdiğimi söylediğimde.
O zamandan beri profesyonel
bir ilişkimiz var.
Ben Ayyüce Kızrak,
elektronik ve haberleşme mühendisiyim,
doktora öğrencisiyim,
10 yılı aşkın süredir yapay öğrenme
özelinde bilgisayarlı görü çalışıyorum.
Bugün de size yapay zeka
kavramıyla birlikte gelen
makine öğrenmesi
-machine learning dediğimiz-
-deep learning dediğimiz-
derin öğrenme nedir, ufakça bahsedip
aslında bugün bulunduğumuz dünyada
ve gelecekte nasıl bir yol izlemeliyiz
fikirlerimden bahsedeceğim.
Artificial Intelligence yani Yapay Zeka,
1950'li yıllarda ilk kez kullanılan
bir tabirdi, bir kavramdı.
2. Dünya Savaşıydı,
Almanlar "Enigma" diye bir şifreleme
yöntemiyle haberleşme sağlıyorlardı
ve bu şifreyi çözen matematikçi,
kriptoloji uzmanı,
bilgisayar bilimlerinin babası
ve 2. Dünya Savaşı'nın kazananı
olarak nitelendirilen
Alan Turing'den söz etmek istiyorum.
Alan Turing 1950 yılında Mind dergisinde
yayınlanmış olan makalesinin
daha ilk paragrafında,
"Can machines think?"
Yani "Makinalar düşünebilir mi?"
sorusunu sorma cesaretine sahip
ve aynı makalenin sonunda da,
Evrensel Turing Makinesinin tanımını
yapacak kadar vizyoner biriydi.
Peki Evrensel Turing Makinesi nedir?
O dönemlerde de, bu dönemde de
aslında tek spesifik problemlere yönelik
çözümler üretmeye çalışıyoruz
yapay zekayla.
Sadece otonom bir araç,
sadece chatbot
-- sohbet eden bir robot sizinle --
ya da yüzünüzü tanıyan bir sistem.
Fakat insan böyle değil,
canlı böyle değil.
Bu problemlerin tamamını
çözebilecek bir yapıya sahip.
Alan Turing de; "sonsuz tane problem için
sonsuz tane makine üretmek,
program yazmak,
efektif bir çözüm değil,"
dedi 1950 yılında.
"Bu yüzden, canlının öğrenme sistemini,
kendi kendine öğrenmesini
programlamalıyız" dedi.
Düştüğümüzde nasıl kalkıyorsak,
suya atladığımızda nasıl yüzebiliyorsak
ya da daha önce hiç karşılaşmadığımız
bir problemle karşılaştığımızda
buna fikir yürüterek
nasıl cevap verebiliyorsak.
Konuşmaya başladığım andan beri
öğrenmekten bahsediyorum.
Peki öğrenmek nedir?
Bir makinanın öğrenmesini
sağlamak istiyoruz
ama biz nasıl öğreniyoruz?
Küçük bir çocuk olduğumu varsayalım.
Daha önce hiç sıcak kahveyle dolu
bir fincana elimi uzatmadım.
Uzatıyorum,
elim yanıyor ve çekiyorum.
Vücudumuz sensörlerle donatılmış durumda,
biyolojik bir yapımız var,
dokunduğum anda yaşanan
kimyasal reaksiyonla
sinir hücrelerim boyunca
bir elektron akışı gerçekleşiyor.
Bu elektronlar beynimde elektriksel bir
sinyal olarak tahminleme yapıyor,
yüzey sıcaktır diyor,
o insan güvenilmezdir diyor,
şu okulu tercih etmelisin,
o pembe ceketi almalısın diyor.
Bu tahminleme yöntemi
fiziksel bir elektriksel işaret,
bunu matematiksel olarak
modelleyebiliyoruz.
Matematiksel olarak
modelleyebildiğimiz bir şeyi,
programlama yöntemleriyle
elektronik bir karta aktarabiliyoruz.
İşte bunu yaptığımız zaman
basitçe bir sinir karar
sistemine yapay olarak
bir fiziksel ortamda
çalıştırabilir hâle geliyoruz.
Vücudumuz sensörlerle dolu dedim
ve bu sensörlerden aldığımız
bilgileri değerlendiriyoruz.
Yapay zeka kavramı da aslında
50'li yıllarda bu şekilde başlayıp
günümüze kadar tanım değiştirmiş,
evrilmiş bir kavram.
Daha 80'li yıllarda
daha çok kural tabanlı dediğimiz,
"Öyleyse şöyle olsun,"
"Şöyleyse böyle olsun" gibi sistemlerken
şu anda daha çok veriden öğrenen,
veriyle beslenen
ve kendi kendine öğrenen sistemler.
Birsürü sensörümüz var,
fakat bunların içinde bir tanesi çok özel.
O da görme,
çünkü beynimizde,
gördüklerimizi değerlendirmek için
en fazla enerji harcıyoruz.
Bu yüzden aslında
güçlü makinalara ihtiyacımız oluyor
yapay zekayla ilgili
sistemler tasarlarken.
Benim de özellikle
çalışma konum olduğu için,
bu konu üzerinden
size izah etmeye çalışacağım.
Beynimiz gördüklerimizi
bir seferde algılıyor zannediyoruz.
Ben buradan size baktığım zaman;
insanları, koltukları,
insanların birbirleriyle
olan ilişkilerini,
üzerlerindeki kıyafetlerin
renklerini, dokusunu,
diğer eşyaları, cinsiyetleri,
duygu durumlarını
veya burada olan olayın tamamını
bir seferde kavradığımı zannediyorum.
Ama anlaşılıyor ki 50'li yıllarda
nörofizikçi Hubel ve Wiesel'in
memeli canlıların
beyninden aldıkları sinyalle
aslında gördüğümüz her şeyi beynimizde,
görsel korteksin içerisinde
katman katman değerlendiriyoruz.
İlk katmanlarda, daha basit dediğimiz
kontrast içeren kenar köşe
bilgilerini algılarken
katmanlar ilerledikçe
nesneleri, dokuları,
renkleri, canlıları,
insanları -- insanları özellikle,
çünkü bu konuda
çok iyi evrilmiş durumdayız --
olayları ve daha kompleks
ilişkileri anlıyoruz.
Bunların her biri katmanlar
boyunca gerçekleşiyor.
Peki, biz bunları katmanlar
boyunca gerçekleştiriyoruz.
Öğrenmenin de nasıl tasarlanacağını
aşağı yukarı biliyorsak
makine öğrenmesi dediğimiz
kavramla karşılaşmış oluyoruz.
Bu kavram özellikle
80'li 90'lı yıllarda çok popülerdi,
akademik yayınlar hep bunlar üzerineydi.
Bir araştırmacı kişi --
mühendis olabilir,
akademisyen olabilir --
bu kişi bir görme problemini
ele alacağı zaman,
örneğin bir araba sınıflandırma işlemi
yapacağı zaman araba mı değil mi diye,
arabayla ilgili özellikleri çıkarıyordu.
Arabanın ne tür özellikleri var;
tekerleri vardır
dairesel elastik yapıya sahip,
bir ağırlığı vardır,
yüzeyi parlaktır,
aynaları vardır, camları vardır gibi
birtakım özellikleri belirleyip
bu özelliklerle
o yapay sistemimizi besliyordu
ve sonucunda bu özellikleri yoğunlukla
barındıran -- olasılıksal olarak --
arabadır diyorduk.
Biz insanın kendi kendine öğrenme
modelini baz almıştık en başta,
ama burada bir yanlışlık var,
bir terslik var gibi.
Güzel, mükemmel sonuçlar da
elde edilmişti
fakat ben annemden arabanın
ne olduğunu öğrenirken
"Anne bu ne?" diye sorduğumda,
annem, "Hmm, kızım şimdi
arabanın tekerlekleri var
dairesel esnek, yüzeyi parlak"
falan demedi.
Ben "Anne bu araba mı?" dedim,
"Evet, araba" dedi.
"Peki bu?"
"Araba"
"Yok, o traktör."
"Hmm, tamam. Peki bu?"
"O da araba."
Gerçek dünyayı temsil eden
çokça örneği gördüm
farklı renklerde, farklı ışıklarda,
farklı tasarımlarda, farklı büyüklüklerde
ve çok veriyi görerek arabanın
ne olduğunu anladım.
Artık şimdi bir fuara gittiğimde
hiç arabaya benzemeyen çok fütüristik
tasarıma sahip bir araba da görsem,
onun araba olduğunu anlayabiliyorum.
Daha derin,
yani insanın, canlının sinir sistemini
modelleyecek daha büyük modellerle
daha çok veriyle beslendiği zaman
sistemin adına "derin öğrenme"
demeye başladık
ve 2000'li yılların ortasından beri
çok başarılı sonuçlar ürettiği için
oldukça da popüler.
Mutlaka siz de duymuşsunuzdur.
Size Mark Smith ve Serpil Hanım'ı
tanıştırmak istiyorum.
Mark Smith, 2005 yılında en iyi erkek
oyuncu dalında Oscar adayıydı.
Serpil Hanım da geçtiğimiz yıl kurduğu
organik tarım start-up'ıyla
vergi rekortmeni oldu,
desem inanırdınız herhâlde.
Ama bu iki insan yüzü de,
yapay zeka tarafından
üretilmiş ve gerçek değiller
ve sizi aldatabilecek
kadar da başarılılar.
Ki en başta da söylemiştim,
insan en çok gördüklerini değerlendirmek
konusunda enerji harcıyor
ve en iyi de bir başka insan yüzünü
tanıma konusunda evrilmiş.
Peki size Mark Smith olarak tanıştırdığım
kişi neden Hollywood starlarına benziyor?
Aslında bu sorunun da
cevabını az önce verdim.
Sistemlerimiz veriden besleniyor
ve eğer sizin sisteminizi tasarlarken
kullanacağınız veri kümeniz
gerçek dünya kadar
çeşitli bilgiyi barındırmıyorsa
ya da birtakım bilgileri
daha fazla barındırıyorsa,
yanlıysa yani bias'a sahipse
sisteminiz ne kadar yüksek
performansa sahip olursa olsun
o yöne doğru kayacaktır.
Microsoft'un Tay örneğinde olduğu gibi,
Twitter'daki chat-bot
insanlarla konuşarak öğrenecekti
ama insanlar ırkçı söylemlerde
bulunup küfürlü cümleler kurduğunda,
evet çok güzel öğrendi bunları
ve kullanılmaz hâle geldi.
Mark Smith de
Google Görsellerle beslenmişti
ve Google Görsellerde benim,
sizin fotoğraflarınızdan daha çok
Angelina Jolie'nin
Brad Pitt'in fotoğrafları var.
Dolayısıyla sistem yanlı bir sonuç üretti.
İlk kez 2014 yılında üretilen insan yüzü
2017 yılında bizi bir Hollywood
starı gibi kandırabildi.
Bu durum dikkate alındığında
2018 yılında Serpil Hanım diye
tanıştırdığım kişi üretildi.
Unutmayın 10-years-challenge diye
bir şey vardı geçtiğimiz günlerde.
Kendi şu anki yüz görüntülerimizi,
10 yıl önceki yüz görüntülerimizle
kendi isteğimizle sosyal medya
hesaplarımızdan paylaşarak
aslında insan yüzünün 10 yıl içindeki
değişiminin özelliklerinin
sistemler tarafından
çıkarılmasına izin verdik
ve daha başarılı sonuçlar elde ettik.
Bilgisayarlı görü konusunda özellikle,
insan başarısının üzerine çıkılan
konular var yapay zekayla üretilen.
Peki neden bu kadar çok
yüz üretip ya da veri üretip
böyle sentetik verileri
kullanma isteği içerisindeyiz?
Neden böyle bir şey yapıyoruz?
Dediğim gibi, sistemlerimiz
veriden öğreniyor
ve veri toplamak, veri depolamak,
veri transfer etmek,
maliyet ve elimizde
sınırlı miktarda veri varsa eğer
bunları çoğaltarak sistemlerimizi
test etmemiz daha kolay oluyor.
Bu kadar başarılı sonuçlar elde ettiğimiz
zaman aklımıza gelen soru işareti,
"Ya bir dakika, beni kandırıyor.
Ben o insanın gerçek olduğunu zannettim.
Bu benim mesleğimi de elimden alabilir.
Hatta insanlığı yok edebilir!"
Bu düşüncelere gark olabilirsiniz
fakat insanın hiçbir şekilde
yanılmayacağı bazı konularda da
büyük kırılganlıklara sahip.
Örneğin muffin'le köpek puppy'yi
ayırt edememesi gibi.
Bu kadar kırılgan,
bu kadar basit bir problemi
çözemediği anda,
"Nasıl olur!" diyoruz
ve sistemlere güvenilirliğini,
açıklanabilirliğini tartışmaya başlıyoruz.
Son bir yıldır özellikle
dünyada konuşulan konu aslında,
bu sistemler bu kadar başarılı
sonuçlar üretirken
ne kadar açıklanabilir, gerçekten
o derin katmanlarda neler öğreniyor,
bu öğrenilen şeylerin güvenilirliği nedir,
bunu sorguluyoruz.
Bizi kandıracak insan yüzlerini
üreten bu zeka
nasıl olur da muffin'le köpeği ayırt
edemez, bunun da çok örnekleri var.
Fakat yine de hayatımızın
vazgeçilmez bir parçası.
Özellikle tavsiye sistemlerini
hayatımızın her noktasında kullanıyoruz.
Pazar günü televizyonu açtığımız zaman
bize hiç aramamıza gerek kalmadan
sevdiğimiz tarzda
bir film önerdiğinde mükemmel
ya da işte evden çıkıp işe giderken
tam bizim müzik zevkimize uygun
ve daha önce tanımadığımız bir grubu
keşfetmemizi sağladığında
ondan daha iyi bir uygulama yok.
Geçtiğimiz gün annem beni aradı
-- bu arada annem teknolojinin
tüm nimetlerinden faydalanan birisidir --
yana yakıla, "kızım doğruyu söyle,
bizim telefonlarımızı mı dinliyorlar?
Verilerimizi mi çalıyorlar?" falan.
Bir dakika anne dedim,
ne oluyor önce bir konuyu anlayalım,
niye senin verini çalsınlar.
İşte benim gözlüğüm kırıldı,
babana mesaj attım,
sonra kahvemi koydum,
oturdum Instagram'da takılıyorum,
karşıma gözlükçü reklamları çıkıyor,
nereden biliyor benim gözlüğümün
kırıldığını, gözlükçüye gideceğimi?
Biliyor çünkü bu sistemler,
verilerimizden besleniyor
ve sen yeni bir sosyal medya hesabı
açtığın zaman anne
bir önceki sosyal medya hesabına
genellikle bağlıyorsun.
Çünkü neden Facebook'a bağla,
Google'a bağla diyoruz;
aynı bilgileri tekrar girmek istemiyoruz,
bir sürü kutucuğu işaretleyip geçiyoruz.
Veriden öğrenen sistemler,
evet sizin verinizden faydalanıyor
size daha iyi performans sergilemek için
fakat bir yandan da siz birçok verinizi
aslında açmış oluyorsunuz.
Olaya bir de şu boyuttan bakalım.
Pazarlama stratejileri için
yıllardır kullanılıyor evet
ama şöyle haritadan yükselin
ve tüm topluluğa bakın dünya haritasında
ve elinizde sağlık verileri
olduğunu düşünün.
Bunların tamamının da
anonimleştirilmiş olduğunu varsayalım,
yine de hangi coğrafyalarda
hangi hastalıklara bağışıklık daha düşük,
hangi gıdalar bu bağışıklığı
düşük olan hastalığın
yaygınlaşmasına sebep olabilir
ya da iyileşmesine,
bu bilgilere sahip olabilirsiniz.
Bu bilgilere sahipken bir biyolojik silah
üretmenize de gerek yok zaten,
o yüzden hangi verileri
ne kadar ölçüde açıp
ne kadar ölçüde korumamız
gerektiği konusu da ayrı bir tartışma
ve ben bu konuları metroda
konuşulurken duyuyorum
yapay zeka hakkında, veriler hakkında.
Açıkçası mutlu oluyorum
ama bu yıl olduğu gibi 90'lı yıllarda da
halkın arasında sıklıkla
konuşulan bir konuydu.
Sebebi de dünya satranç şampiyonu
Garry Kasparov'un
IBM'in Deep Blue yazılımına
yenilmiş olmasıydı.
Peki bu yazılım gerçekten
çok akıllı mıydı?
Dünya şampiyonuydu Garry Kasparov
ve onu yenen yoktu. 97 yılıydı,
hayır ama insandan
çok önemli bir üstünlüğü vardı.
İnsan çok kompleks bir yapıya sahip,
bunu hepimiz kabul ediyoruz.
Ben şu anda dünya üzerinde
bulunduğum konumu biliyorum,
az sonra işaret ettiğim yere
rotamı hesaplayıp
aynı anda size ne söyleyeceklerimi
düşünüp konuşabiliyorum.
Bunu bir robota yaptırmak
belki ömrünüzü alabilir
ama bir satranç tahtasının önüne
oturduğumuzda, işler değişiyor.
Çünkü ben bir sonraki hamlem için
5 ya da 10 olasılığı belli bir süre içinde
hesaplayabilip ve görebiliyorken
bu yazılım yüzlercesini
bir çırpıda hesaplayabiliyor
ve bu hız Garry Kasparov'un
yenilmesine sebep oldu.
Benzer bir olay 2017'de de yaşandı.
Çin mitolojik oyunu Go
satranca göre çok daha
fazla olasılık barındıran,
daha büyük bir tahtada oynanan bir oyun.
Şampiyonlardan birini,
Ke Jie'yi gözyaşlarına boğdu.
Google'ın Deep Mind şirketinin
AlphaGo yazılımıydı
ve aslında ta o 50'li yıllarda
Alan Turing'in önerdiği kendi kendine
öğrenebilen sistem dediğimiz
pekiştirmeli öğrenme,
reinforcement learning'de programlanmıştı.
İyi bir şey yaptığında ödül ver,
kötü bir şey yaptığında ceza ver şeklinde
ve gerçekten akıllı bir sisteme
insanın yenildiğini gördük gözyaşlarıyla.
Ardından Lee Sedol'u da yendi,
o da büyük bir hezimete uğradı.
Hissettikleri şeyi görsellerden
anlayabiliyorsunuz;
üzüntü, endişe, mutsuzluk.
Evden çıkıp işinize gittiğinizi düşünün.
Aracınıza bindiniz,
bir anda "Ah, evdeki kahve makinasını
açık mı unutmuştum!" diye endişelenirken
sevdiğiniz bir insandan mesaj aldınız,
bir anda mutlu oldunuz,
arabayı kullanmaya devam ediyorsunuz.
O sırada haberlerde
dövizin doların arttığını duydunuz,
para kaybettiğiniz için
yine üzülüyorsunuz.
Bir yandan araba kullanıyorsunuz, o sırada
karşıdan karşıya bir insan geçiyor,
bu duyguları barındırıyorsunuz
ve araba kullanıyorsunuz.
Bu insanlar yenildiğinde üzülmüşlerdi.
Peki AlphaGo kazandığında sevinmiş miydi?
Hayır.
Kazandığında, Deep Mind ekibi sevinmişti
çünkü kazanan sadece yapay zeka değildi,
kazanan yapay zeka ve insandı.
Birlikte çalışmışlardı ve sevinmişlerdi.
Yapay zeka sistemleri -- bizden farklı
olarak evet üstünlükleri var --
fakat sezgileri, duyguları,
yaratıcılıkları sınırlı ya da yok.
Bu yüzden biz kendi üstünlüklerimizi
kullanmaya çalışmalıyız.
Örneğin rutin işler;
sabah bir bantın önüne oturup
akşama kadar bir pantolonun
aynı paçasındaki ipliği kesmek
o insanı otomatikleştirmek ya da
makineleştirmekten başka bir şey değil
ama bizim amacımız bu değil.
Yapay zeka ve insanın kazanması.
Doktora gittiğinizde size daha hızlı
bir şekilde teşhis koyabilmesi için,
sürekli evrilen,
mutasyona uğrayan bir hastalığı,
dünya çapında bir anda araştırabilmesi
ve onu kullanabilmesi,
onun için kullandığı
o akıllı sistemle size teşhis koyması,
yapay zeka ve insanın birlikte çalışması.
Aynı şekilde hukukta, eğitimde.
Ve ben bilmiyorum,
doktorun gerçekten problemi ne
ya da bir hukukçunun problemi ne.
Eğitimcinin,
bir restoran işletmecisinin.
Bu büyük Performans Sanatları Merkezi'nde
yaşanan problemler ne bilmiyorum
ya da sanatın gerçekten
neye ihtiyacı olduğunu bilmiyorum
ve onlar da belki
bu yaşadıkları problemlerin
bu akıllı sistemlerle çözülebileceğini
bilmiyor olabilirler.
Bu yüzden mutlaka
bir araya geliyor olmamız lazım,
dünyada en çok konuşulan konulardan
biri son 6 aydır:
Human-in-loop, human-centred ai denen,
insanı merkeze alan,
insanın refah düzeyini arttırmak için,
sosyal iyilik için kullanılması
ve bunun yapılabilmesi için
mutlaka disiplinlerarası çalışıyor
olmamız gerekiyor.
İnsanların mesleğini elinden alacak değil;
biz yaratıcıyız,
bizim kendimize özgü
duygularımız, sezgilerimiz var
ve biz verimlilik için değiliz,
verimlilik robotlar için.
Biz bu yaratıcılığımızı,
bu fikir alışverişini sağlayarak
gerçekleştirebiliriz sadece.
O yüzden birlikte çalışıyor
olmamız gerekiyor,
çok disiplinlerarası
çalışıyor olmamız gerekiyor.
Ciddiyet, dikkat ve anlayışla
takdir edip yargılamamız gerekiyor.
Gerçekten hep birlikte,
uyum içerisinde ahenkle
çalışıyor olmamız gerekiyor.
Bu sadece mühendislerin problemi değil,
her alana entegre edilebilecek bir problem
ve uyum isteyen bir problem,
hep birlikte çalışmak için.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)